the Haitian government the U.S and the
U.N Secretary General have been pushing
for an international deployment to Haiti
for almost a year but it was only at the
end of July that the U.S found a country
willing to lead the mission Kenya this
vote was the next procedural hurdle the
draft resolution has been adopted both
Russia and China abstained but didn't
veto the resolution they had questioned
the wisdom of authorizing an
international Force without first
settling on its Rules of Engagement
Haiti contains a lot of history of
irresponsible foreign interference that
is what gave rise to the downward spiral
that Haitians have not been able to
overcome for years they also insisted on
a more comprehensive arms embargo on
Haiti at the moment a large proportion
of the gang's weapons are being smuggled
in from South Florida
we explicitly request all countries take
all steps to cut off at their sources
the channel through which Haitian gangs
obtained Small Arms light weapons and
ammunition
this is not a United Nations
peacekeeping Mission its last
stabilization Force left in 2017 having
been accused of widespread sexual abuse
and sparking a cholera outbreak that
killed some 10 000 people
that record appeared to be on the mind
of the U.S representative at the
security Council importantly this
resolution recognizes the need to learn
lessons from past missions and calls for
safeguards to promote respect for human
rights and accountability Kenya will now
have the legitimacy of a U.N security
Council mandate as it attempts to
augment its proposed force of 1 000
police officers with those from other
nations and overcome objections at home
and abroad about the mission not least
as a result of the poor human rights
record of the Kenyan police force itself
resident supporter Prince expressed
mixed feelings about another
International Force
the force will not be able to dislodge
The Gangs because they're hiding in
every corner unless they destroy the
houses to chase the bandits away
I would like the multinational forces to
come and make things better for the
Haitian people because we're tired the
MSS as it's called is currently
authorized for one year and will be
reviewed after nine months Kenya's
foreign minister says he expects boots
to be on the ground by next January
sherbertansi Al Jazeera the United
Nations
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera